[Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning i
wanted a good
miami throwback to start the day florida
is experiencing a big influx of new
residents in the wake of the pandemic
the miami area has seen a 15 increase in
tech
professionals it has welcomed more i.t
and software workers in the last year
than anywhere else in the country by
contrast new york city lost
18 percent of his tech workforce and the
bay area lost nearly
35 percent we recently spoke with miami
mayor francis suarez the 43 year old
who's in his first term
told us it's his personal mission to
transform miami into the next great tech
capital
people often counter brand miami they'll
say well miami is just a
you know hospitality town or just a
retirement place
or this is just a moment in time and for
me this is a movement
thank you all for coming here today
mayor francis suarez is a miami-born
republican and cuban-american
with an appreciation for traditional
cafeto
and he's waging a gorilla style
marketing campaign
trying to lure entrepreneurs to miami
with the goal of turning paradise city
into tech's new frontier that invitation
to come to miami first came in the form
of a tweet
it did it got about 2.7 million
impressions it was a tweet
from deleon from the founder's fund who
said hey guys what if we move silicon
valley to miami
and i tweeted out they called the tweet
heard around the world four simple words
how can i help that tweet and others by
a leading silicon valley venture
capitalist
helped inspire entrepreneurs to flock to
miami for an impromptu tech week
earlier this spring mayor suarez
embraced the moment by launching his
cafeto tech talks
and hosting business leaders in town
hall style conversations
we have very little homelessness in
comparison with major cities of very
little crime in comparison with major
cities
when you say i want to build the city of
the future how would something like that
look like
look i have two children technology's
here to stay whether you're republican
or democrat it's not a partisan issue
and so for me as you think about how do
you create high-paying jobs which have a
generational impact
you have to attract the people that
create these companies
people like jason richmond who relocated
from new york to miami during the
pandemic
i've seen a growing sort of ecosystem of
talent pools coming here to miami over
the last couple of months
richmond works at safecraft a data
company that provided information to
scientists
local governments and even the cdc to
aid in the pandemic response
trying to figure out where can i go
somewhere warm with low taxes
healthy lifestyle and this was the
natural choice have you found the
conditions for
your company to thrive in this
environment yeah so i came down here
uh to eventually build an office for the
team but i think that what the pandemic
has proven is that with the sort of
acceleration
of digital transformation you could
really work from anywhere
right but not everyone is as optimistic
about miami's future
when forests burn carbon journalist
david wallace wells
author of the uninhabitable earth warns
that the fate of this futurist paradise
could be largely underwater
of all the cities in the u.s you know
miami may be the most
dramatic illustration of at least the
crisis of sea level rise you've already
started to see
the army corps of engineers developing a
series of plans to protect major
american cities from sea level rise
and their plan for miami includes sea
walls
on the mainland it does not even attempt
to protect any of miami beach or the
rest of the archipelago
which is essentially an acknowledgment
from the army corps of engineers
that that land is practically speaking
lost
miami will still be there in 2050 but it
will be dealing with so much more
climate struggle than we have today
we're one of the few cities probably in
the world that's spending hundreds of
billions of dollars to make sure
that miami is as water resilient as any
city on the planet as a resident of
miami myself
there are days where we don't have a
drop of rain and still we
we have flooded streets because of high
tide
climate change seems to be a a yes
urgent matter but
also a long-term challenge yeah um
how do you balance those two well first
of all i have a great great incentive to
think long-term
in my two children but there have been
multiple climatic phenomena so we know
what the challenges are
we're not putting our head in the sand
pretending like they don't exist
mayor suarez says he's also working to
ensure that any technological boom
benefits everyone especially since miami
has a higher poverty rate than the
national average
it's something we're very intentional
about that's why we say that we don't
just want to miami it's here forever we
want to miami it's here for everyone
we're a community of immigrants this is
very natural for us to invite people
from outside
and when they're coming here not just to
buy property but to build jobs
which builds careers which has a
generational impact on families
that for me is what makes it truly
gratifying
and to make sure nobody gets left behind
the city is providing underserved
students with
fry free high-speed internet access for
two years
and it's also working with programs to
train adults so they have the skills
necessary
for the modern economy gail anthony and
i think
you know it's interesting the mayor is a
rising star in politics
in florida so a different kind of
republican than what we're seeing right
now yeah
you can really feel his enthusiasm for
what he wants to happen in the city but
when i think about floor i go to miami
sometimes for a long weekend
because it seems very uh very
fast very fast to me it is i mean very
fast
we'll see if this holds you know if this
is a movement not just a moment like yes
it's very interesting transformation
he's in the middle of the challenges
ahead though are clearly
are clearly pretty dramatic yeah but it
could change
how we think of miami also the other
thing about florida the taxes
everybody loves the lack of taxes in
florida we're seeing that people from
new york and california moving to
florida that is very
attractive